- Hello!
I feel like I've had your
family here at this point
on this show.
I've had a couple of your kids.
I'm just sayin', I've had
a lot of your family here.
- Well, one time, we should
bring us all together here.
- I know, (laughing) that's-
- Exactly, yeah.
- Will it be more exciting?
Are y'all fun at Thanksgiving? (laughing)
- It would be great, yes.
Absolutely, yeah.
- Awesome.
- It's great to have Paul.
- I know, y'all have
met, obviously, right?
- Yeah, yeah, of course.
I mean,
he has played several times
when I did the "Letterman" show.
- Exactly, yes.
- [Arnold Schwarzenegger] And we always-
- We have got a funny
connection though, you and I.
I don't know if you realize this,
but before you were, you
know, a great politician,
you made an album, a vinyl album,
called "Arnold Schwarzenegger's
Total Body Workout."
You working out to the hits of the 80's,
and you worked out to one of my songs,
"It's Raining Men," that I
co-wrote with Paul Jabara.
You have, "One, two,
up, down, up, down, up."
(audience laughing and applauding)
I'm telling you,
I wanna go to the studio
with you too I think.
- Oh my God, you were like
the original playlist guy,
making playlists for workouts.
- But I mean, that's why that
record was such a big hit.
- [Paul Shaffer] I'm sure it was.
- It was not because of
me going up and down,
and doing my squats, and my leg lifts,
and all of those things,
but it was because of your music.
- Well, you were no fool.
- [Arnold Schwarzenegger] I mean-
- [Kelly Clarkson] Ugh, "It's
Raining Men" is a great song.
- I know, exactly, I have good
taste when it comes to music.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- [Paul Shaffer] We all know that.
- You must love mine.
Okay... Um, I'm just
kidding, I'm just kidding.
(Paul laughing)
(audience applauding)
Welcome to our New York studio.
- What do you think why I'm here?
- Exactly, you're like, "I'm
only coming for the music."
- I love your music too, exactly, yeah.
- No, welcome to our studio.
This is our first
season, here in New York.
We're very excited, and we're
very excited you're here.
- [Arnold Schwarzenegger] I know,
and I'm the first guest, yeah.
(audience cheering)
- Do you remember, like when
you first moved over here,
like do you have a first
memory of New York?
- I remember coming here in 1968
and traveling through New York,
then going to Los Angeles
and living on Muscle Beach.
- Yeah.
- But then I came back in 1969,
and then won the Mr. Universe
contest for the fourth time-
- Like you do, yeah, yeah.
- In New York.
And so I remember that,
and then right after that,
I was offered to do
this movie in New York.
- Yeah.
- That was a really great beginning,
I finally realized my dream.
And then afterwards,
I chased my dream and continued
taking acting lessons.
And then, my movie career took off,
and it was one of those
kind of lucky things.
- When you first moved here though,
you obviously have a thick accent still...
I do too, welcome to Texas.
But-
- I have an accent?
- What?
(audience laughing)
So weird.
No, I was just gonna
say, when you moved here,
was there a lot of like
lost in translation
when you're having
conversations with people?
Like, you thinking you're saying something
and they hear something else?
- Yeah, it's very difficult
to adopt to a new language,
you know?
I remember that right in the
beginning, a friend of mine,
a Jewish friend of mine said
that, "I know Austrian food.
There's this Hungarian
restaurant on Fairfax Avenue,"
he says, "I'm gonna take you there."
So he took us there and I ate
this unbelievable, you know,
vegetables and meats and
everything like that.
And then I said to the guy, to the owner,
he came to the table, he says,
"Can I help you, do you want some more?"
And I said, "Yeah, can I have
some more of your garbage?"
- Your garbage?
- [Arnold Schwarzenegger] Yes, and so-
- So, what were you trying to say?
- And so my friend...
So he says, "What do you call my food?
Say this again, what do you call my food?
You called it garbage?"
And then my friend jumped in and says,
"No, no, no, what he
actually meant was cabbage.
He wants to have some more
of your cabbage." (laughing)
I mean, things like that will come up.
(audience laughing and applauding)
It was like crazy, yeah. (laughing)
But I mean, he understand
after, "Oh, cabbage,
you want more of the cabbage."
I said, "Yeah, yeah, cabbage.
I'm sorry."
- Pretty bold of the guy though.
Like, you looking like you,
and like him being bold enough to be like,
"What did you say?"
I don't know if I'd...
I'd have just been,
"Exactly, it's garbage, bye."
I would've just left.
I heard this crazy story, it's random,
and I have to know if it's true.
Did you accidentally break
a first lady's ankle,
and how does that happen if so?
- Well, George Bush invited me...
When I was
the Chairman of the
President's Council of Fitness,
he would invite me always to Camp David.
This was 1991/92, when he was president.
And he would invite me up there,
literally like every month.
He loved hanging out with
me and working out with me.
We'd do throwing horseshoe, and you know,
going running up there and all this stuff.
And I was one time up there in the winter.
And so he said to me, he says,
"I have this great sled,"
which was not really a
sled, it was a toboggan.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so with sleds, you can
steer the sled with your feet,
but that one I couldn't really steer.
So we go down the hill in the snow there,
he's sitting behind me
and he says, "You steer,"
and I did not know how
to steer. (laughing)
So I mean, it's just
going faster and faster,
and all of a sudden we're
approaching this tree.
And all of a sudden, Barbara
comes up behind the tree
and then we just ran into her leg.
And so the poor Barbara Bush, you know,
she had to go to the hospital afterwards.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my God.
- She had, you know, a sprained leg
and she got a cast on it and
the whole thing like that.
But I have to say that they
were very gracious about it
in the way they took it.
(audience laughing)
And you know, I apologized,
I said, "I feel really
bad about it," yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Nobody has
this story, that's incredible.
- [Arnold Schwarzenegger] She
was a wonderful first lady.
- So we wanna talk about your new book.
So it's called "Be Useful:
Seven Tools for Life."
Wait, I have it right here.
(Kelly singing)
How did you come up with seven?
Like, it feels like...
Did you know the number was gonna be that,
like how did you come up with that number?
- The key thing is that
you pick specific things
that really helped you in life.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Mm-hmm.
- And that make your life
fortunate, as as my life is,
just extraordinary, and to be successful.
But I think it's important to mention,
I always say, "I'm not a self-made man."
Because so many people write stories,
"Schwarzenegger is an
example of a self-made man,"
and I always say, "I'm not because,"
I say, "Everything that I've achieved
is because of the help of other people."
- Absolutely.
But, that's a true leader.
- Some American brought me
over to America, Joe Weider,
I remember he brought me to America.
There were the training partners
that helped me all the time to
train and to become champion.
There were bodybuilders
that brought over dishes to my
apartment, blankets, pillows,
a black and white TV, a radio.
I mean, all this stuff.
I mean, you have no
idea what it feels like
when you are this
immigrant, this foreigner
that has $20 in his pocket
when I came over here.
And then all of a sudden,
people show this generosity-
- It's love, yeah, kindness.
- And help you like that.
And there's love and inclusion.
It's important to recognize
that you're not a self-made man
because then you realize
how many people helped you,
and then you realize how many
people you have to help also.
- Yeah.
- Because if they helped you,
now you have to give something back.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And I have to help other people.
That's why in the book,
the last chapter is "Break your mirror."
You know, the mirror that makes
you always look at yourself-
- Yeah.
- Break that mirror and
just look beyond that,
and you will see the millions
of people that need your help.
That's why in the in the 70's,
I got involved with Special Olympics
and I started becoming
the national trainer
and then the international trainer.
And then later on, I became
the Chairman of the
President's Council of Fitness
under President Bush.
And then later on, I
started afterschool programs
because I realized that 70%
of the kids come from families
where both of their families are working.
- Yeah, both the parents, yeah, yeah.
- So both of the parents are working.
So now, there's no one there
for the kids in the afternoon.
- Yeah.
- So, what happens?
- Or there's just one
parent in the household
so they have to have
somewhere to go, yeah.
- It's a major, major challenge.
Programs are very important
because it gives you,
in the afternoon, we provide
tutoring for the kids and-
- That's amazing.
- Homework assistance, sports programs,
arts programs, and all that.
- Yeah.
- And just the key thing is
to have adult supervision.
So they are between three and six o'clock,
having a great time, studying,
getting better in different areas-
- Learning teamwork,
learning all this, yeah.
- Exactly.
And their education improve tremendously
and their grades improve tremendously.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- So, it's really a win-win situation.
And the parents can work
without having the headache.
So this is just one of the things-
- 'Cause of worry.
- That I do to give back to the community.
And then of course,
when I ran for governor,
I turned my back on
doing movies every year-
- Yeah.
- And making this
$20,000,000 a movie a year.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And then just said,
"Okay, I'm gonna go and
just be a public servant,
serve the people of California."
- But when you're
blessed, you bless others.
- So, it's all about giving back.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I agree with that, I agree with that.
Well I wanna come back
to the one you were talking about earlier,
"Breaking Mirrors."
So it's open your mind
and break mirrors, right?
What exactly does that... I love that.
- "Opening Your Mind" is
another chapter in there,
which is "Open Your Mind
and Shut Your Mouth."
- Yeah.
Oh. (laughing)
- [Arnold Schwarzenegger] Yeah, because-
- You know what?
I could use that one. (laughing)
- No, no, but I'm telling you
because I wanted to just let people know
that one of the secrets of my success
was that I always was like a sponge.
I listened very carefully
what people have to say.
I am a very good listener,
and I think it really
helped me in my career.
It helped me in my acting career,
it helped me in my political career
that I was more interested in
listening rather than talking.
And so I think it's
just one of those things
because so many people are
so concerned about, you know,
what they have to say.
But you don't learn
anything if you say it-
- If your mouth is moving.
- And you learn when you listen.
You know, God gave us two
ears and only one mouth.
(Kelly laughing)
- So, we might as well
just listen twice as much
and talk less.
I mean, that's what the
chapter's all about.
- I feel like God sent
you here today for me.
(everyone laughing)
I feel like this is an intervention,
and my crew is like, "Yeah, listen."
(audience laughing)
Well, let's do another break.
This is incredible.
Everybody, y'all gotta go get this.
Arnold's new book
is called "Be Useful:
Seven Tools for Life."
It's out now,
and everyone in the
audience is getting a copy!
(audience cheering and applauding)
You can also find Arnold's
companies that are online.